-Our next guest is
a fantastically funny
actress and comedian you know
from shows like
"Living With Yourself"
and "This Way Up."
She stars in
"Home Sweet Home Alone,"
which premieres Friday
on Disney+.
Let's take a look.
-I swear to you that boy was
not in the house when we left.
-And where do
you think he was, Stu?
At the -- at the
Four freaking Seasons?
-He had the fish curry
on the plane.
We probably got a hard 30 before
we're going to see Stu.
-You do realize that,
because of you,
I'm in Japan and my 10- --
10-year-old son
is at home by himself.
-Yeah, but -- but first-world
problems, you know.
-First-world...
-Stop it!
Listen, listen! Stop it!
I got that at Brookstone!
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Aisling Bea,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Aisling, it is great
to see you again.
-Thank you, Seth.
It is also great to see you.
Well, the first bit's
gone real well!
-We are natural.
People know we're friends.
You're a -- This is a good night
for you to be here.
You're also a Taylor Swift fan.
-Yes, yes, yes.
I'm the headline act
this evening.
Glad to be here.
I was -- Well, I didn't --
'Cause I didn't run into her,
which I was kind of happy about,
because the last time
I saw Taylor Swift was when
I accidentally ended up
in her apartment.
-How did that happen?
-In her sitting room.
And -- Which is not like, "Oh,
that's what I told the police."
I -- Of course
we were going to have
maybe a moment
where I could explain.
-Right.
-But, no, she ran away.
-So she saw you tonight
and remembered,
"This is the strange woman who
showed up in my sitting room."
-Well, I think her security
might have, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But I --
Yeah, basically, I was --
When I was doing
"Living With Yourself,"
I was living in New York.
And my friend was here, and
we were going to go ice-skating,
And I'd had
a long old day at work.
And, so, I was dressed up, ready
for ice skating, kind of --
you know, your snow boots,
giant, you know --
paraphernalia, a hat, ice pick,
the whole shebang.
Not an ice pick.
And he was like, "Oh, I'm just
at my friend's house,
having a beer if you
want to come and join us."
You know, he's an actor.
And I was like,
"Yeah, yeah, I'll join you,
but what time are
we doing ice skating?"
He's like, "Oh, yeah, we'll
definitely go ice skating.
I'm just having a beer
at my friend's house."
And I was like, "Okay."
And he was like, "Um, yeah, just
come to the door, ring the bell,
and, you know,
someone will come down."
And I was like,
"Okay, sounds a bit 'cool.'"
You know, a bit retro.
And then this man came down.
He was, like, a really
big man in the lift.
And I was like, "Oh, hi!
Thank you so much
for having me."
He was like, "Yeah."
And I was like,
"Oh, what a warm man."
And then we went up
in the elevator,
and it opened and I was in
Taylor Swift's sitting room
with Taylor Swift in her
sitting room playing pool.
And I was --
She looked so beautiful.
And she looks and looked like
Elsa from "Frozen,"
just kind of like,
"Hi, welcome."
And I was there dressed like
Olaf just like, "Aaah!
Oh, my God! Aaaah!"
And then I --
We didn't go ice skating,
because we were --
-Why would you? Yeah.
-I kept on trying to look at
my friend, being like,
"Why didn't you tell me
that we were going to be
in Taylor Swift's house?
I would not have
worn this out...
Yeah, I'd love
a gin and tonic, Taylor.
Thank you so much."
-It's very rude.
-It is very rude.
Because I'm a massive fan,
so to just turn up --
And then I've just felt
creepy by my existence.
-Yeah.
-So I was like...
"Lovely smell."
-I am so happy that
you're here, because you --
And I'm happy to see
you're recovered.
You did catch COVID.
-Yes, COVID.
-In the fall.
-Yeah.
-You had to miss
a lot of things,
so we're very happy
to have you here in person.
-Yeah, I did.
I got the --
Oh, thank you very much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's all you need nowadays.
I survived COVID.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, I did.
Double-vaxxed, but I got
the stars variant,
so contracted that one.
And, yeah,
but it was my first week off,
and I'd organized my best
friend's bachelorette party.
And then there was her wedding.
And then the next day
was her son's christening,
and I'm one of the godparents.
And that was
all during my 10 days.
-So you couldn't do any of it.
-Couldn't do any of it.
But I did -- I was like,
"Well, how can I sort of be
there in spirit in some way?"
-And you -- I think this is
a very good solution.
-Yeah. It's kind of like
a new COVID thing.
Just send a cardboard cutout
of yourself.
-I mean, that is just --
And, also, like,
just a fun cardboard cutout.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm glitzy. I'm fun.
I'm a great wedding guest.
You know, and people
did say afterwards --
they were like,
"You were so much more chill
than your normal personality
at the wedding.
We should hang out more,
yeah, because you were just
better to be around."
-I notice your co-star from the
fantastic show "This Way Up,"
Tobias Menzies.
-Tobias Menzies.
-Who is, I will say --
Yeah, Tobias, you know,
now an Emmy winner from
"The Crown."
-Yep.
-You kind of
knew him when, right?
-I what?
-You knew him when.
You, like -- You got in on
the ground floor.
-I though you said,
"I knew him win."
And I was like, "Seth,
that's not great English."
"You knew him win!"
-You knew him win.
You call me.
You call me and say,
"Tobias win."
You knew!
-You knew him win Emmy!
So natural.
-Aisling, it's Seth.
You knew him win!
-You knew him win Emmy!
-I hang up now.
-No, stop, stop.
-Mm!
-Knew him win Emmy,
but, also, yeah, he was --
He's the other godparent.
-Ah!
-So, we also -- So, in my show,
"This Way Up" --
All available on Hulu.
Watch it, please.
-Fantastic.
-He plays
a character called Richard,
and he's also Prince Philip
in "The Crown,"
which is what
he won the Emmy for.
But we're also godparents
together of this child,
and the other godmother
is actually Emerald Fennell,
who wrote "Promising Young
Woman" and won an Oscar.
-Yeah.
-So I'm, like, the crappy one.
-And I'm literally
a cardboard cutout.
So I'm not, like,
the quality beef of godparents.
-Years from now, he'll say,
"So, the award winners came."
-Yeah, the award winners,
and then in spirit
was the sort of --
You know the damp one?
We threw her in the lake,
and she floated, yeah.
So, yeah -- So --
But in "This Way Up,"
the second series I've actually
set in March 2020,
which you find out
as it is goes along --
So, technically,
it's now a period drama,
and it's a bit more like
"The Crown."
So that's what I've done.
-Oh, very wise.
Very wise move
for the award pandering.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Did you -- Making this
"Home Alone" remake,
was "Home Alone" a film that you
were aware of growing up?
-Yeah! I didn't grow up in,
like, you know, the North Pole.
Even the North Pole
is a bad reference,
because that's where
Santa Claus lives.
Yeah, yeah, I was massive --
But I do think, like,
at the time,
when movies came out in America,
you were like, "Oh, God,
it's come out in America.
All we need to do is wait for
one to three years,
and we'll see it soon!
Ahhhh!"
So, stuff used to come out like
a year or two later
than America, but, like,
we got, like, to --
If I was to tell
my baby self that,
"You're going to become
an actor and end up in the
'Home Alone' movie," I think
I'd really have understood that
as a sign of things
are going well.
-Yeah, things are
going very well.
Now, I will admit that
not a lot of --
We didn't get a lot of Irish
kid stuff over here.
It was not a two-way street.
-That is a giant loss
for you guys.
-Yeah. Well, you sent this,
and I'm not sure
it was a giant loss, because I
think this is disturbing.
-Let me tell you something.
You're about to
get canceled in Ireland.
-Okay.
-These were our children's
entertainer presenters.
They hosted
a show called "The Den."
These are two aliens
who came to Ireland from space.
That was the destination
that they were most --
And then, eventually,
they sort of adopted
a puppet turkey from Dublin,
who then went on --
Do you know what
the Eurovision is?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, The Eurovision,
what he does --
The Eurovision is, like,
a massive competition
of, like, musical things
from around Europe,
plus Australia for some reason.
And we sent Dustin the Turkey
as our representative to sing
on behalf of Ireland.
Just in case
you're wondering, like,
"How could you sum up
a culture?"
We sent him to sing
on behalf of Ireland.
-Yeah.
-But he's a massive --
He's a massive deal there.
-How did he do?
-Oh, we lost.
We did not win at all.
-So, he probably finished
highest of the Turkeys.
-Yeah, I'd say so.
Well, you say that,
but then...
-It is always such
a delight to see you.
-Thank you so much.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
You guys, that's Aisling Bea.
"Home Sweet Home Alone"
premieres Friday on Disney+,
and "This Way Up"
is streaming on Hulu.